what's up guys if you're new to the  channel remember to hit like and  subscribe and leave a comment down below  let's get going all right gamers we have  some crazy stuff to talk about today but  before we start only about 21 of you are  actually subscribed so consider  subscribing it's free and you can always  change your mind later thanks guys okay  we've got some wild whacky stuff to talk  about today so don't forget to smash  that like button show me some love by  subscribing and comment down below your  favorite ice cream mine is just tonight  though starring jimmy fallon all right  guys let's get into it squid game  breaking records  mr beast